because I'll tell you why because the
songs I did seriously are more
embarrassing than the songs I do as
David Brent they are so [ __ ] cringy I
bet I get a lump in my throat
not like Jim now they're just awful
pretentious comedy pretentious
electronic not the name of one that
you're in battle with the name of on
this is the title of a song I can't do
it with the title [ __ ] hell I don't
know what to do just the title you're
needlessly I can tell you the ones that
are released as well within Iran are
dancing and they're not too bad more to
lose so it was quite a little day and
you know but not about the one that you
were thinking you know which one were
you thinking that you like I was lost
the most embarrassing song I've ever
written was one song called Johnny
Wright and it would kill me it was about
being in a band right Oh God it was
things like what Johnny wants to do is
buy a set of wheels or to join a sleazy
band and he wants to die against a tree
is that what they're wants to buy a car
wait the real question was or were you
Johnny Johnny young always better to do
so ha I'll take the cardigan off why if
they're wrong one that's a real rock and
roll dream here yeah
we thought it was better to burn out
than to fade away yeah Johnny was gonna
play with me it was after the band that
we're having a bit of success and then
we did this song and a few other equally
awful songs right but you know rock and
roll songs right think oh god you think
all this loads no I can't actually can't
think of it that's the one that was our
best one that's why I can remember it's
the story about Johnny so Johnny why buy
a car is why say it was a join the
sleazy birthing was devised against the
tree
he wants to OD in LA he just gets sick
and catch the plague oh right they're
playing HIV reference about 96 Disney
Warner does he want to [ __ ] died in a
car accident or an OD on the tree what
does he give it to the trend he's just
made summation on heroin driving in the
trees underground bow alright by the way
the fact that he bought a couple cars at
least one is okay the other ones up
against the treatment it's fine he
caught the plague you hit a tree right
okay because it makes me what would I
have to done for you to go [ __ ] me
that's a great song let's see gypsy lady
exactly that's why red songs about cuz I
think there's an ironic get out quality
Street I've become more obsessed I went
back and keep listening today but you
know what it's about time that somebody
pointed out that in 1986 nades really
was the new play
what Johnny wants to do
it's by settled wheels or two
John a sleazy band he wants to die
against a tree but he just crashes in
his room dies on stage and stumbles home
what Johnny wants to do that's enough
that was really that was really
something special my special secret time
on Netflix
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app